[Music]
hey keep your hat like that for this one
i'm hip-hop nick you look like dopey
dude what up i'm hip-hop [ __ ]
re-branded looks sick
try to make me flinch this is
poppy see this how many points hey i
want to sit over there and do that with
you guys two one action how long have
you guys worked at the same company for
how long
does this one count do you know what
your record is like for working at the
same place two years right now eight
years if it's this one it's 15 years
surprise you haven't been fired
i tried to fire myself but bart wouldn't
let me we're going to vote you guys out
dude i don't have a board meeting we're
going to vote
can we do that here well this is a very
toxic company so we need a doubt can we
have a dow
a decentralized autonomous organization
so yeah we can vote you guys out for
good anonymously yeah
come on dude i'm trying to leave i
really am but i can't i'm not allowed
just go public yeah who's the oh that's
good of this company like oh you guys
the hr they killed themselves someone's
getting sexually harassed they're dead
now
we get sexually harassed by the
employees steve keeps touching me under
the table oh dude dude when the bosses
are credit carding you i'm not worried
about touching them dude when bart
stands up we're always looking at his
ass
we can't see it that's his [ __ ] piece
[ __ ]
pornographic films together many times
yeah it's not just me by the way yeah
it's mainly you made other people do it
too but i'm thankful for it what started
stevie weeby started it but yeah it's
his fault if we had an hr i feel like
they would go hey why aren't you
harassing anyone
that's true what's wrong with you what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you man touch
someone's ass our hr would have been
like dude it's been like 10 minutes
since you haven't [ __ ] said [ __ ] to
anthony you guys need to start talking
more [ __ ] right now yeah can we put
cameras in the toilets please all right
rh resource humans
that is a jkh replace the bidet with a
camera with a gopro so there's a man in
brazil
man in brazil he's been working at the
same company for 84 years and nine days
84 years what the [ __ ]
dude he's a hundred [ __ ] years old is
his company
he's been in child labor
so this guy's making peppers farm
cookies
in 1938 he started work as a shipping
assistant when he was 15 years old at a
textile company in brazil called
industrious renault i think man what a
loser he's been working that long and
he's not the boss yeah he's not the boss
he's still an assistant okay he can't
retire
that's sad and that's sad that's sad
well he's a legend now apparently we're
talking about him no what adult we're
legendary damn he's older than anybody
else in there probably huh
how does he work what does he do now
apparently he used to walk barefoot to
school to study then he would uh go home
he had he was an exceptional student
with a brilliant memory a great
attention to detail but due to financial
problems at home he had to start working
to help his family out so then he went
to this mill with his mom to apply for a
job and because of uh his strong
proficiency proficiency in german he was
hired
because he worked for nazis in argentina
he was hoping to clothe and warm nazis
dude he's bilingual too yeah that's fire
every time he tries the boss tries to
fire him he's like do you know my
connection
i got adolf i'm speed dial [ __ ]
because he's still alive he's still
argentina let's go yeah that's why we're
gonna double team ever heard
[Laughter]
so he believes
he believes in having a job he thinks
that it gives you a good sense of
purpose commitment and routine i agree
yeah especially if you're old
you got [ __ ] to do i think when i retire
i'd work yeah you gotta find something
that'll be a cashier or something i'm
gonna be a cashier or [ __ ] mob
retired
mop doer
yeah what's a mop door [ __ ] guys that
[ __ ] do a mop wow
on the ground
so you're gonna have a tijuana private
show
it's the mop doer joe jitsukawa and he
does a five minute like stand-up bit i
used to hate brooming but i don't mind
mopping i like mopping too yeah i want
to see if you can get a mop show that's
to la bomba
[Laughter]
that'll be tight that's it this guy has
worked here 84 years
nothing happened at the end of it wait
what kind of company is it now it's
still still
how did that company survive so long is
it like a [ __ ] public like
one of those boring long lasting
companies you know like a [ __ ]
wonderful factory or something [ __ ]
xerox or some [ __ ] like a seafood
refrigeration district one of them yeah
it's like one of those like we all like
it's highly essential but not remarkable
yeah nobody cares that you do that kind
of work coca-cola how do you how do you
find news for this show by the way like
because this is
really scraping here uh well i went to
the guinness world of records website
dude this is on cnn dude people are
talking about this a lot right now yeah
people will be talking about like roe v
wade or cnn plus getting shut down oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
how are we trying we're careful here
welcome to america bro maybe they do
that in the uk but not in the u.s we're
here trying to deflect those have
obvious opinions this attracts people
from the real topics okay okay moving
away it's not even real
wouldn't you think it's real what do you
think that cnn plus that's just a i
don't know i have a rumor
are you a subscriber to cnn plus no we
are
we love it it's good content dude even
the netflix stock is tanking you guys
mentioned that everything's tanked are
you talking about 20 are you into crypto
or stocks
do you play crypto or stocks no i i just
keep trying the news i have index funds
that's it that's how i invest index
funds
how boring that's like as boring as this
company listen listen safe and boring
and predictable stand up high high risk
career right oh yeah so you need
something that's low risk yeah that
makes sense
i'm risky on youtube risky you got to
double down on everything
everything dude listen or else what's
the point of living
not dying eat some raw chicken once in a
while yeah
raw dog hooker you know
oh i've done that
raw dog buy some penny stocks and raw
dog hookers that's your life i don't
mind that
i never [ __ ] a fan that's gonna be my
life's greatest regret do you have fans
i never not really
but i guess and when i had fans they
were like 13 year old boys that would be
kind of weird
they're old enough for kisses now right
yeah i don't know what that means that's
your wife that's what's your wife think
if you if it touched a 13 year old boy
well if they'd be like hey that's not a
woman
you know it's not cheating you get a
hall pass for that i don't think so i
don't think so not in america probably
the uk yeah
you guys are wild in the uk man
you guys have nerdy on television can we
don't you i don't watch tv either on
french tv they do the chicks always wake
up like this yeah
but there was like oh wait last night
they always have it's like a croissant
croissant commercial yeah and then they
wake up and they have an espresso and
croissants they smoke a pack of
cigarettes together
yeah that's lunch you know
wait bart joe who's uh who's the longest
uh working or stating connection to jk
person still besides you two like who's
the longest i don't know we fire a lot
of people michael michael yeah you guys
are falling out with the previous like
old cast members is that drama oh
there's so much plenty of drama
i knew it i knew it everything's
amicable yeah we're falling out
literally as we speak even within this
group dude like we [ __ ] hate each
other
it's already not working we started this
trying to throw a coup already we're
like let's uh create a dao and uh ask
some people
yeah michael probably over ten years
maybe michael you're like ten years
eight to ten years i'm just trying to
have my pride is it michael and then me
you've been you've been here you guys
you guys been here like as guests but
not on payroll
and you haven't felt the abuse until
recently so you're not a true member
okay i'll just start paying my dudes
that would be true i was on the jk news
instagram and i saw you pop up in 2015
which is pretty crazy so that's seven
years yeah that's pretty long yeah and
you know what's funny in that clip
you're talking about you're asking about
what vr porn is like
and now and a couple weeks ago you're
telling us what it's like
i'm the only progressive guy here you
know i'm trying to still get my research
out so i can bring content
vr you ever tried it no but like
you watch it you jerk off you finish and
then now you're like your hands dirty
what what do you do how do you know that
i hope you put in your hands just
imagine it
look at you
raw dog hooker guy
yeah how do you do it oh no you just
have to wipe everything with the
anti-bacterial wipes after but you can't
see like i don't [ __ ] know man what
do you mean you don't know what do you
mean
velcro like empty back your hand soap
next to the the headset and just squeeze
it out like wash it that's nice you guys
don't masturbate with rubber gloves on
what no wait when you had vr porn you
still used your hands
you didn't use like a dark knight or
something just so you could completely
be like free we've already talked about
it none of us have purchased it yet
except for maybe joe what about a
flashlight you didn't use the phone i
didn't have an address to send it no he
already explained that you just got to
have your homie help you up yeah yeah
assistant yeah
that's why you got player two and that's
why ryan was over the other day
he's like ryan i'm finished and he comes
and he takes it off that's what happens
oh it licks your dick clean yeah
hey that's a good homie hook up dude
this guy popsicles is crazy he's in a
french market having a popsicle why is
it so warm possible
why am i choking on these popsicles
a warm popsicle like a tootsie roll just
get to the center man why is it like a
gusher
it's a nice veiny popsicle this game has
a lot of levels yeah
popsicles pumping at me
this game man we're done
[Music]
you